hey everybody,
this is Tony from Tony Neighbors Consulting.
today we're gonna answer the question, what is diversity?
so diversity is an expression
and a representation of the human experience.
basically a cross section of humanity.
so you should be looking at race, gender,
sexual orientation,
social economic status, language,
age, ability, disability.
all those different things all contribute to diversity
and are very important for us to focus on
in the prioritize as organizations and businesses.
I wanna make sure that we are not shying away
from censoring racial diversity especially.
race and racism is such a strange invention by humans
that we often wanna shy away from.
was very important that we face it bravely
and confidently
so we can really get the best out of ourselves
and our organizations.